we did anticipate that there will be
neurological complications right from
the very beginning i've been studying
viruses since the 80s
when the aids pandemic started and it
was the same story there too
a lot of people have long-term cognitive
problems even if their virus is well
under control
what affects the brain can be extremely
devastating because it can affect your
personality your ability to think and
concentrate your mood and those things
that make us a person as a whole
when sars cov2 emerged many were
initially focused on its impact to the
lungs
it soon became apparent that kovid takes
a toll on the entire body from the
gastrointestinal tract to the brain
autopsies have revealed devastating
damage in the brains of those who have
died from covid
blood vessels were damaged they were
inflammatory cells around the brain we
found that there were immune cells in
the brain itself and we found antibodies
stuck to the blood vessels we knew that
they were attacking the blood vessels i
had expected that we will see a lot of
virus in the brain because the virus
affects the nose to our surprise we
didn't find the virus in the brain there
are few people
that have reported detection of virus in
the brain but they find very very small
amounts and it doesn't explain the
pathology that we see
most of these autopsies were conducted
on individuals who had severe cases of
covid
less is known about brain damage in
those with long covid symptoms that
persist for weeks after what is often a
mild stage of acute infection
studies estimate that up to 30 percent
of people develop long covid after an
initial sars kovi to infection and that
women are at greater risk than men
the symptoms can include fast heart rate
shortness of breath and various
neurological issues
we've actually seen over time now that
we've seen hundreds of patients and lots
of people have been reported in
literature too
there are these kind of major categories
one of them is this people call brain
fog where
really your brain is just not
functioning properly for some sort of
cognitive types of tasks things like
concentration memory
people have skin changes where they
basically say wow the sensation on the
surface of my skin is really abnormal
and then another major category that
we've seen is headache
there is the sort of psychiatric
categories where people have rarely had
a much more
acute and profound delusion or psychosis
syndrome i think it's been a real
challenge for patients that they come
into their doctor with symptoms and the
tests that are run are negative and even
things like mri which is a very
sensitive test that can find lots of
changes in the brain for many of these
patients is normal
for a long time we've been using
research tools that can look at more
sensitive measures that aren't things
that we necessarily
use in the clinic but can tell us things
like whether the immune system is
functioning completely normally
or whether there might be very subtle
injury to the neurons in the brain that
you just can't see by looking at an mri
scan
there are three hypotheses that can
potentially explain how long covet can
affect the brain
one is a direct infection
of the virus of some cells in the
nervous system or supportive structures
in the brain second hypothesis is that
there is auto immune responses that are
attacking parts of the brain
that could obviously trigger lots of
different symptoms and long duration of
such responses because once the
autoimmune cells are activated it's very
hard to deactivate them the third
possibility is that there is distal
inflammation happening such as in the
lung
that could stimulate cells within the
brain and trigger a long-term changes in
those cells so a combination of these
could be happening or it could be a
sequential event of things that happens
and they all contribute to this
brain
neurologic issues
long-covid clinics across the world are
trying different rehabilitation
approaches to improve these symptoms
our nervous system has
um
a whole portion of it that is dedicated
toward doing all of the things that your
body
needs to autonomously control
when
that gets knocked out of balance that's
called dysautonomia dysautonomia has
also been reported in other cases of
post-spiral illness
autonomic rehabilitation is a very
personalized and a very delicate
approach to rehabilitating the autonomic
nervous system for most people
that we see with long covert it
typically begins with
very very gentle movements paired with
breath work with a patient laying flat
on their back
slowly performing movements that
increase blood flow into the chest
cavity it's not exercise it's not
aerobic it's it's very gentle we've had
good response to cognitive symptoms from
autonomic rehabilitation i think it's
worth mentioning that
not all cognitive symptoms are from
dysautonomia
and so in some cases we don't move the
cognitive symptoms at all
researchers are also beginning to
conceive of drug treatments that may
address the underlying causes of long
covid a team at the national institutes
of health is awaiting regulatory
approval for an immune modulating drug
trial
plan is to bring in patients we're going
to keep them in the hospital for a week
and one arm will get placebo the other
arm will get
intravenous immunoglobulin and the third
arm will get intravenous corticosteroids
they are sledgehammer approaches they're
not very precise attacks right they
affect the immune system in many
different
ways
vaccination in long-covered patients
have impact on their symptoms some
people feel much better from vaccination
that could eliminate the source of these
persistent virus or bioremnants or you
know something that's basically
persisting in these patients that's
triggering the chronic inflammation
number two some people don't feel any
difference at all but there are some
people who feel worse from vaccination
if a person is suffering from autoimmune
disease for example
the vaccine-induced inflammation might
you know exacerbate the
autoreactive lymphocytes and therefore
making the disease temporarily worse and
the ultimate goal is to try to
understand what we can do to help them
feel better without using the vaccine
because vaccine doesn't work on
everybody but if we can figure out what
triggers the better improvement in their
symptoms then we can try to emulate that
with other therapies
many hope that the knowledge gained from
long-covid research will benefit others
grappling with post-viral illnesses
we have millions of people suffering
from not only this but very similar
related diseases post lyme syndrome gulf
war syndrome
patients they're going from physician to
physician nobody knows what's wrong with
them people tell them well it's all
psychological or anything
but they have real disease
now we have a superb opportunity to
put the best tools that we have
available to us
try and sort this out if we could do
that i think you have a huge impact in
the field